scarlett johansson is suing disney over
the release of the movie black widow
scarjo claims that she was entitled to a
percentage of the box office receipts
but here's the thing disney released the
movie black widow
on their streaming platform disney plus
at the same time that they released
the movie in theaters the movie made 60
million dollars on the streaming service
but only 20 million dollars in theaters
johansen is claiming that the term in
the contract theatrical release means an
exclusive theatrical release meaning
only in theaters for a specific period
of time and not simultaneously on any
other platform disney i'm sure is going
to claim that in fact the term
theatrical release means that they just
have to release the movie in
theaters and that so long as they do so
they can also release it on their
streaming platform at the same time and
they have upheld the contract we don't
have the specific contract in front of
us but it's pretty suspicious that the
plaintiff johansson
has not included that language or at
least is only referring to the term
theatrical release
without any kind of exclusivity clause
attached to it so
she may have a very uphill battle in
this particular lawsuit
but we will see them in court